the Invercargill City Council currently
has eroding and traffic by law out for
submission in the proposed bylaw there
will be changes to the beach and how
you're able to use it so currently most
people come in Dunn's road right here at
the entrance and then they drive to the
left and many people like to park down
here but under the proposed changes you
only be able to come in Dunn's road turn
right onto ferry road and park on this
side you'll also only be able to drive
onto the foreshore these changes may
affect you and we want to make sure that
if you have issues or want to say
something about it you get your
submission in another major change to
how you use the beach is our sand dunes
currently you can use the sand dunes dr
in them and there's no way for us to
enforce it under the new bylaw you will
be written an infringement notice or you
will be given a ticket if you drive in
them and that is to protect them for the
natural environment and also for future
generations one other major change
that's coming is a change to the taste
street parking currently many private
citizens use their vehicles they park
them on the street and they put a for
sale sign and leave them for long times
under the proposed changes you'll need
to get permission from the city council
before you can do this and this is
because it's become a real safety issue
we have cars that double park
pedestrians that are walking around and
we need to do something to address this
if you'd like to do something about this
or you would like to put a submission in
on any of these issues or any other
changes in the proposed bylaw you need
to contact the City Council by January
29th at 5pm that can be in a written
form and you can also get more
information on the website by contacting
WWI CC govt TN z